dans infinity ward le plus gros mystère
du film est imposé par notre fameux
docteur strange ce dernier pendant la
bataille et vue plus de 14 millions de
futurs différents via la pierre du temps
pour vaincre thanos et malheureusement
seule une possibilité sur ses 14
millions montrent les avengers vainqueur
face au titan et c'est réellement
quelque chose qui attise notre curiosité
car strange affirme tout le long du film
qu'il sera prêt à sacrifier n'importe
quel avengers dont notamment tony stark
pour sauvegarder la pierre du temps afin
que thanos ne met pas la main dessus
et contre toute attente au moment du
combat contre tanoh sur titan iron man
est sur le point de mourir face aux
titans et doctor strange marchande donc
avec thanos la vie de tony en échange de
lui donner la pire du temps ce qui va à
l'encontre de toutes ses promesses
danone gagne donc face aux avengers et a
finalement obtenu toutes les pierres
puis à éradiquer la moitié des êtres
vivants dans l'univers via un simple
claquement de doigts doctor strange se
voit mourir devant tony stark lui
affirmant que c'était le seul moyen
mecelec le mystère entre en jeu nous
savons que strange détient la solution
pour vaincre thanos donc toutes ces
actions sont justifiables
mais est ce qui la sauve et tony en
donnant la pierre du temps à thann
oscars ce dernier devait posséder les
six pierres pour que nos héros est une
chance de gagner ou bien car tony stark
serait la clé pour avengers 4 la
dernière phrase de doctor strange
confirme qu'un sacrifice aussi énorme et
est obligatoire
joe russo a d'ailleurs confirmé que
thanos devait avoir la totalité des
pierres dans le plan de strange mais est
ce qu'il n'a pas fait ceci aussi pour
sauver tony qui pourrait être un élément
clé d'un jeune george iv c'est fort
possible
après tout pourquoi sauver sa vie en
échange de la pierre du temps alors que
strange aurait pu directement donné la
pierre déjà qu'il n'aimait pas tony si
en plus il n'est pas utile à la victoire
strange l'aurait sûrement laissé tony
stark n'est pas un avengers comme les
autres c'est un génie de la technologie
et fait partie des plus puissantes
avengers du mc
non pas à cause de sa puissance mais de
son intelligence de sa capacité à
s'adapter à n'importe quelle situation
et surtout à prévoir l'avenir nous en
avons l'exemple avec la conception de
vision un personnage parfait pour
défendre la population et aider les
abonnés recevoir même les remplacer au
cas où ils seraient dissociées néanmoins
intéressons nous maintenant à captain
marvel et antoine et la guêpe
ces deux films se passeront avant une
finity voir dans la timeline mais
sortent bien après une finity war au
cinéma pourquoi car ces deux films
pourraient bien apporter de nouvelles
cartes pour la suite ventures iii
si ces derniers sortent après mais se
passe avant c'est qu'ils doivent avoir
des éléments de réponses des solutions à
apporter pour la réussite des avengers
pour commencer entre man 2 se tournera
clairement vers le chant antique une
bonne parallèle où le temps et l'espace
sont nuls
antoine étant le premier protagoniste
est revenu de cette dimension nos deux
héros scott et la guêpe essaieront de
manipuler cette zone pour mieux s'en
servir dans le futur et il est même fort
probable que ces deux derniers
réussissent à faire revenir janet van
dyne femme de hank pym et première femme
à être le personnage de la guêpe disparu
dans le champ quantique
ils la retrouveront d'ailleurs
certainement dans le film maintenant si
nous nous tournons vers captain marvel
carole denver se verra attribuer son
film sur ses origines en mars 2019 et
le plus intrigant et que ce film se
passera dans les années 90 d'ailleurs
quelque chose d'intrigant aussi reste la
scène post générique infinity ward
unique fiori avant de disparaître fait
appel au personnage de captain marvel
via un appareil très anciens confirmant
que le film sur carroll denver se
passera dans les années 90 mais l'un des
gros problèmes et comment vont-ils la
faire venir dans une finition noire qui
se passe chronologiquement trente ans
après captain marvel et bien cela
pourrait être grâce au chant quantique
si le temps et l'espace sont absents
dans ses dimensions captain marvel pour
s en servir grâce à antoine élaguer pour
atteindre notre époque
ce qui me fait penser ce pti d'ailleurs
et qui les soupçonnaient que captain
marvel posséderait des pouvoirs en
rapport avec le chant quantique et
qu'elle sera justement la héroïne la
plus puissante du mc eu d'après ce qui a
été déclaré
de plus chaque personnage du mc eu est
présent dans avengers 4 et des photos
des personnages ont même fuite et où
nous les voyons habillé comme à une
époque antérieure de certains films en
voyageant à travers les époques pour
atterrir à celles d'in fi nit hiwar nos
trois héros pourrait arriver dans ces
époques ne réussissons peut-être pas
manipuler facilement le champ quantique
mais ce qui est sûr est que carole
denver c'est la clé pour vaincre thanos
teasé dans infinity ward les
réalisateurs insiste sur le fait qu'elle
est le héros le plus puissant du marvel
cinématiques universe
elle pourrait alors prendre le rôle d'
adam warlock dans les comics emportant
le gant de l'infini pour vaincre thanos
si elle en est réellement capable
c'est une option pour continuer
j'aimerais ajouter que si captain marvel
tony stark et ant man sont tous les
trois réunis de grandes choses
pourraient arriver
tony stark semble être la clé du plan du
docteur strange si ce dernier le sauva
quant à carole elle semble être la clé
définitif pour vaincre thanos notamment
grâce à la scène post générique
puis antoine semble être la clé pour
justement amenée captain marvel à notre
époque et effectuer d'autres actions
grâce au chant quantique a ainsi que son
pouvoir de devenir énorme imaginer leurs
trois compétences unis
captain marvel avec ses pouvoirs et sa
puissance dans une armure
nanotechnologies créé par tony stark et
avec le pouvoir de brandir commente man
elle serait dévastatrice surtout si elle
est le personnage le plus puissant du mc
hugh danos ne pourrait rien faire
néanmoins ne mettons pas de côté d'or
qui vient d'à peine se révéler avec une
puissance phénoménale
à tel point qu'il a failli tuer thanos
ce que nous pensions être le dernier à
ce gardien aura bien du travail dans
avengers 4 puisqu'il a été confirmé que
valkyrie sera dans le prochain opus en
compagnie d'autres à ce gardien qui ont
réussi à survivre et échapper à la noce
mais n'oublions pas les autres avengers
restant cependant ne sous-estimé pas
danos c'est pas parce qu'à wenders 4
sera synonyme de la victoire des
avengers qu'il n'y aura pas de
conséquences déjà loki heimdall et
visions sont réellement mort et nous
pouvons entamer notre deuil
je vous laisse le bénéfice du doute pour
l'eau qui sachant qu'il fait partie du
casting d'avengers 4 la seule réelle
survivantes et gamme aura qui est
enfermé dans la pierre de l'âme cela
était confirmé mais nous en reparlerons
dans une autre vidéo si vous me demandez
en commentaire robert downey junior et
chris evans ont terminé à leur contrat
avec marvel après avengers 4 et je
maintiens ce que je disais dans mon
trois théories des héros vont mourir
nous arrivons à la phase 4 et marvel
commence à réellement aller de plus en
plus loin dans son univers nous avons
quitté la terre depuis un bon moment
notamment avec les gardiens la galaxie
nous avons fait face à des ennemis comme
des célestes des éternels legrand anos
et de nouveaux héros plus jeune et plus
forts arrivent de plus en plus regardées
le déséquilibre âge entre natacha et dr
strange par exemple ou même simplement
captain america mis pas mal en retrait
dans infinity ward
cela fait maintenant une vingtaine de
films que les avengers d'origine sont
présents et certains commencent à être
mis en retrait ou poussés vers la sortie
natacha banner tony captain oeil de
faucon je ne veux pas être mais 10
mais attendez vous peut-être à quelque
chose de macabres la relève de ses
personnages arrivent et même déjà
présentes certaines rumeurs parlent même
de personnages qui pourraient prendre le
costume d'iron man afin de remplacer
tony ou bien un captain buzz qu'il
pourrait il le fait déjà dans les comics
seul tort commencent à exploiter toute
sa splendeur et aura un rôle à jouer en
compagnie de nos trois héros tony
captain marvel et ant man
ce que nous savons est que avengers cats
sera très différent d'infiniti voir et
la seule chose qui a été confirmée était
que gamme aura est enfermé dans la
pierre de l'âme
attendons nous donc à énormément de
surprises de la part de marvel et fait
confiance à doctor strange
tony est un visionnaire captain marvel
et surpuissantes et ant man maîtrise le
champ quantique
enfin j'aimerais d'ailleurs vous
partager les vidéos de deux autres
vidéaste qui ont aussi partagé une très
bonne vision concernant le plan de
doctor strange
il s'agit de mon ami aéronefs et de
captain pop corn je vous invite à voir
leur point de vue les vidéos sont
disponibles en descriptions merci à ceux
qui laisseront un pouce bleus et qui
partageront cette vidéo n'hésitez pas à
me suivre sur twitter c'est très
important
cet argot rock et que le line up soit
avec vous
[Musique]